ok...
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Resident Evil.
Now, that party wasn't what I thought it would be,
but I guess he promised a party, and he did deliver
even though it was a really shitty Birthday Party.
But now I've got this D-Series Head
From this screaming, bound up corpse.
I don't know why it died screaming,
if it is dead AT ALL,
which is very uncertain in these times.
Creepy Voice: Finally!                                                                           Yeah, finally okay I got that, what does that mean for me?
I still don't even know!
Did I even change out my inventory? No I didn't, I need to get all of my shit again...
I'll be right back I'm gonna grab all my stuuuff.
Okay, so I should be good. I got my knife, my gun, my grenade launcher and my shotgun along with one first  aid.
I don't have a lot left
buuut... I'm going to have to make do.
I don't know how well this is going to go, but at least my defense coin on me,
and I've got the brain and the arm.
I don't know what good that's gonna do, but let's find out!
Is this place still on fire? Ohh good the fire went out..
Let me just save after I've done all that kerfuckling.
Alright so now the mystery remains
as to what is ahead because it's not on my map so, I'm supposed to be rescuing
Mia and Zoe, but I still don't know where Mia and Zoe are...
OOOHHHH
This isn't a party room!
Oh, this is the opposite of that!
What do you expect me to do here?
Oh, okay.
Alright then, I'm trying to pay very close attention at absolutely anything.
They seem to be loading me up with ammo again which is very good. I haven't had to use it in the last sequence.
So that's good
Alright.
OH, my crank a yank!
Oh, I forgot about my crank a yank!
Oh good.
I can probably--
Woah
Hey, I see you up there!
Can I get ya?
Yeah I can, okay.
I still don't know what good that does me..
Hopefully something.
So I gotta go get my crank a yank out of this thing
but I'm full up.
Dammit.
Alright, I'mma have to leave the lock picks behind and hope that I come across one again...
Psycho Stimulants too because I just don't have enough room,
for absolutely everything.
I mean I can drop off the crank as soon as I'm done with it I suppose but,
I just want to make sure that I have absolutely everything I need going forward.
'Cause I don't know how far this swamp goes.
I mean I know it's Louisiana and there's probably a lot of swamps but,
you think there would be some sort of designation along public access routes.
That didn't make any sense at all!
Ah fuck
And I'mma go off the base assumption that I don't need the crank a yank anymore.
And I'm gonna put it away at great risk to my own personal belongings.
Alright I'm taking a risk, I better not need it again; if I have to come running back, I'm going to be very pissed!
Alright
So it's time for Lucas to get his come-uppance--
I don't think it's time for a grenade launcher to the face just yet.
But that's gonna happen, I'mma..
I'm gonna grenade him to the face.
And hopefully be able to rescue Mia out of all this
I still don't know if that's even gonna be possible!
I still don't know if Zoe knows exactly what she's doing
with this serum.
Like, how does she know this?
Who told her this?!
Its not like this family ever researched this and found it out for themselves. No.
They must have had some sort of training
Or someone telling them what to do so that they would
be able to execute these things,
and also test other people for this.
Ehhhh question of the day?
Boobytrap?
Ahh, thank goodness gracious! Ohhh.
Okay. Just the wiiind. Alright good.
Alright.
So I got burner fuel but, I don't need it because I don't have a burner.
eeee I want to make sure I have absolutely everything that I neeeed.
Let me just open the rest of the bullshit--
OHH GOD DAMNIT!
OH IT'S A FUCKING CRANK-A-YANK
I DONT FUCKING HAVE THE CRANK-A-YANK
UHHHHHHHHHHH.
Also theres one magnum ammo.
Now I'm- I'm willing to guess that the magnum must be an unbelievably powerful gun
if you only get one bullet at a time.
So, maybe it might be a good idea,
maybe it's like the grenade launcher--
Oh fucking hell. Hi!
No. No.
AHhhhHhha    HAhHhhHa
You got fuuuuuucked up.
You got fuuuucked up! ANYBODY ELSE? Oh hey!
There's a whole bunch of other people. Alright then.
Alright, let's see if I can do this.
BLOP!
*Awkward silence combined with gunshots*
CMON. Oh no you don't.
*shotgun fires*
One down!
You've got--
You've gotta be close. THERE WE GO!
Just one more pop-shot.
Alright, Not too bad!
Woah..
What, is there more?!?!
Oh, there is more!
What are you doing over there?
Stop being an ***.
*Awkward silence combined with gunshots pt. 2*
Got one down--
*Shaman chanting*
♩ bop bop ber dop bop ♩
And you're dead!
Man they knew that you would have to go back for the Crank-A-Yank!
They planned for you to go back for the Crank-A-Yank!
*speaks to himself* They planned you would be a big dumb doo-fee doof Markiplier.
*still speaks to himself awkwardly* I know, they're out to get me and they're against me.
Son of a bitch.
It better break after this one.
It better fucking break.
Nope
Oh, ok I took it then, alright.
So I got to get the magnum ammo.
'Cause that's apparently very important.
Now the question is do I risk going back and dropping off
the Crank-A-Yank if I need it one more time...
And I must-
fucking fucking fucking NOPE!
Awww fuck you. YEAH THAT'S RIGHT!
YEAHH-- oh boy.
I was in the middle of something there--
woah
Ok, you're dead, Yes? Okay.
Definitely dead.
I hope so.
Anyways, so I'm going to take the risk!
But, If I get even one mo--   WOAH hey. Fucker-- fucking--
*Awkward silence with gunshots pt.3*
waaah- BOOPY
♩  BABA BOP BOOP BOOP BABADA BOOP BOOP♩
What the fuck?
Thought I got-- Oh you had your arm in front of your face
okay that would explain a lot.
Alright, well...
Party's starting really early here.
They better give me another box at some point,
or another save point
*gasp* They do! Ohh, they're so nice!
Oh, they're so nice and that's a lot of shotgun shells which is very concerning for me.
SO what I need to do is I need to put away this one magnum ammo..
I need to put away the crank-a-yanker...
I need to put away...
I probably shouldn't've taken the arms with me or the psycho-stimulant, I didn't need either of those
But at least I'm prepared and that's what matters...SO!
What do we got here... Gunpowder...  We got another--
Is this a booby trap?  Nope, more shotgun sheeellsszz...
I think it knows what I like the most.
Oooh, hell yea.
Okay so that-- that definitely reinforces the idea that grenade launcher...
Uhhh
You know what? I'm gonna put these back!
Maybe I don't need 'em on me right now because it would be a little be a little illogical about that, and then
maybe, maybe just maybe,
maybe maybe baby--
Maybe I would be able to, uuh,
meet back with Zoe...
I-in the.. trailer
and then be able to cook up whatever monstrosity serum that they're trying to do.
Up the rickety stairs we go.
To what death?
I don't even know.
Don't even think I wanna know.
And it better not be another cranky-yank!
Oh.
Hi. Okay, so you are just up here
by yourself. Ok.
Hello.
Mia, Zoe.
Hi.
Mia. Mia?
Oh.. Uh-oh.
That's a bad sign. That's a trap!
Mia!
R-remember how you tried to kill me?
That was awesome. Good times, huh?
Okay...
Well that was.  Uneventful.
Zoe?
Hi.  Nice to meet you!
Oh, ok.  Pleasantries aside, then.
What happened to Southern hospitality?
(haven't you been with an evil family in Lousiana the whole game)
OHHH OK
I GET IT
I PUT 'EM AWAY FOR ONE DAMN SECOND...
I don't know what I'm doing,
I'm an asshole!
That's what I'm doing.
What's an arm without without something to crank?
I got 'em.
What're you going to do with them THERE?
Y-you're literally tied up.
I was assuming...
There's enough for two..?
What does that mean, there's enough for two?
What're you gonna cook it in a soup can?
Can I have that bag?
Okay...
So-- Ohh, ok.
Okay.
WOAH, HEY
WOAH!! HI!! WOAAH!!
WOAAAH
Hoooooly shit!
What are you?! Are you Daddy?!
Ohhh no, are you Lucas?
OWW!
Oh boy, ok, new ammo!
Hoh boy, oh boy, oh boy
This ain't good.
I see ya!  I see your weak spot.
Oh you got LOTS of weak spots.
Ohhh
How in the fu-- WOAAAOOAAAO
Ugh, gross.
Grrrross.
Holy shit
Okay this is bizarre and fucked up.
W-- HEEEEYEYAY
I dunno WHAT you're gonna let stand
WOAH
Holy shit
Woooaah
Hey dude!
Wooaah
M-- uh oh.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY!
Oh, fuck
I dunno what's effective against you.
Woah, hey!
Alright.
Well, calm down there.
How 'bout you burn up here? That'd be nice.
Oh I see ya, I see  ya.
Weak, I see a weak spot.
Woah.
Ok.
Oh boy, oh boy, where you going, where you going?
Where you going, where you going?
Woah.
Yeah, I'm beginning to think the same thing.
What are you doing?  What are you doing?
Am I supposed to do something--
Oh, hi. Hello.
You blind?
Woah, hey, oh you shouldn't be up here!
Ohhhhkay? Alright
This is surprisingly effective!
Alright.
Can I shotgun that armmmmmm?
Woah.
AHHHH! Oh fucking shit!
Oh that ain't good.
I need this, c'moooon sploosh
Oh fuck , you're HUNGRY?!
Then you should've eaten more for dinner!
Where are you?
Better not eat nothing down there...
Nothing down there for you to eat!
Boink!
Fuck I missed!
I think - I think she's dead. Sorry.
Sorry to be the bearer of bad news
You know what I'm just gonna--
*Daddy groans*  WOOOAAHHH
WOAHHHHHhhhh
What the fuck did that do!?
Oh shit this shit's on fire now that's not good
Ohhh I dunno about that Jack. Woahh boy
Alright out of those...
k
Welp, alright
NO NO NO NO NO NO NO
NO NO NO NO NO NO
He's got like a weak spot on his underside that he's protecting...
oh boy oH BOY OH BOY OH BOY WOAHHH WOAH
OWWW FUCKING I only have one of these left
This is my last one but it'll get me to full
Oh come on give me the shot gun shells
Gimme gimme gimme
WA-HEYAYAYAY! Oh where ya going?
Alright okay
Alright, I'll go- I'll go toe-to-toe with you!
Woah woah woah
Maybe not maybe not I regret, I regret
I have many regrets
Ey Ey Ey first aid good
God I don't- WOAH FUCK
Holy shit,  ohhh this is not what I meant
Oh I see it
Okay I see it WAHEYHEY
NOOOO NO NO NO NO NO NO NO NO NO NO
NO NO NO NO NO NO NOOO NO NO NO NO NO
How 'bout no
Woooo okay, how about no
Okay this guy- this guy is a sack of shit!
This guy is an aggressive son of a bitch!
I dunno if you isss
Okay I'm going to go down now
I shoulda just jumped
That's ok
Oh boy
Hang on I see that last--There we go
Was that the last one!?
Oh boy, OWW WHAT THE FUCK DUDE!?
Woah shit oh shit
OW FUCK I'M TRYNA MOVE!
Heyeyey
It's gettin' dark. Gettin' dark
Goddammit, not what I meant
S'fucking do it
Gimme that, gimme that, gimme that!
Oooh fuck, gimme gimme gimme gimme
Gimme!
Oh my fuck!
Oh my fucking gawd
Yeesh
Going up, going up
up
No I'm not
Youuu didn't want me to be part of the family
Eva was picking me to be the daddy and then you decided that that wasn't a good idea.
Oh shit oh shit oh shit
WaaAA
Aw fuck!
Aw fuck I just don't know where to hit him
Oh boy
Alright, g'byyye
Weeee
Okay, strong for a statement
Whoa! How did you get me there?
Holy shit
I see another eye there
There we go
Whoa
The fuck!
Oh boy I'm outta here
Ooh fuck that shit
Oh fuck that shit right outta there
Oh
What're you doing?
What're you-
Whoooa!
Oh okay
Hang on
OW fffuck!
Oh come on!
I was hittin' the block button
Oh c'mon c'mon c'mon c'mon
C'mon, get up
Whoa okay, alright
Blocked that somehow
Oh boy
This ain't looking good
Come on reload, reload
Splash, I don't have any more
Oh boy
Oh boy oh boy
Death!
Ohh boy
Reload
Ohhh
Did I do it?
Ohhh SHIT!
I did it
Holy fuck, did I do it?
You done for good?
No no don't say that
Don't say that
I highly doubt that you've seen everything there
Ooh boy
Whoa
Well thanks for the help
Hey! Fucking-
Goddammit!
Oh boy
Oh boy ahh that's not good
Okay
Ehh okay
I'll give it a go
HYAA
Habooshki!
Yeah think so
Okay cool
Is he actually dead though?
That's another question that I have to ask
Oh
Wait now I only have one
Ah dammit
Well now I only have one of these!
Aw fuck it who am I gonna give it to?
There was supposed to be one for Mia and Zoey
What would happen if I didn't inject him?
Was that like a choice?
I didn't even realize that
Is there a way that I could, like-...
Is there a way I can backtrack?
I just wanna be certain
I didn't even know it was a choice
I don't even know if it still is a choice
but I'm just like
That seems like a choicy thing because now I only have one of 'em
and I needed one for Zoey and
Mia
Oh no
Wait is this the end of the game?
What?
Am I already at the end of the game?
Oh geez
OH now I gotta make a choice!
Oh fuck
I don't know
Well I mean-
No offense, Zoey, but Mia is my wife
I mean, she tried to kill me but at the same time...
I don't know
Gotta cure Mia I suppose
*fake gasp*
Oh no
That can't be right
What?
Oh no
Oh that can't be the end
Ohh nooo
That can't be it
There's no way
Well that's-
Whoa
Hi there
Oh no
Ohhh nooo
Ohh noo
Heyy
I don't know
How would I know
Yee ohhohohohoh whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa WHOA WHOA
Okayyy!?
What!?
That is not good
I don't wanna *mumbles*
I'm not your mommy
I'mmm not your mommy
I can 100% be assured I am not your mommy
OH I'm Mia
Oh maybe I am
oh ok
Oh just for clarity's sake
Yes, definitely Mia here
Ohh shit
Ohhh shit
Ohh what the hell
Okay so maybe Ethan is lost to the bog now and now I'm cured Mia
With no inventory and "A strange bottle that you found in your pocket after waking up at the Baker estate
It's probably important."
Maybe it's more serum!
Maybe she had it on her the whole time and no one need to worry about anything
So I still don't know if that was a choice I needed to make there
It seemed like, I don't know
Maybe there was no other way to defeat the dad than to inject him because that seemed to kill him  pretty good
and he didn't seem to wanna die in any other capacities so that seemed to be, like, the most appropriate way to do it.
but
Man, what if you had chosen Zoey? Wha-What would that even mean?
That would be-That would be so cruel to your wife!
I mean I know he-
Uh, your wife tried to kill you and everything but even so-but now, apparently Ethan is gone
Woah!
Ethan?
Eth-Annee!?
woOOOAH
woaaah woOOah
OOOOKAAY
That's normal.
Yeah, I've seen less normal things than that.
That's pretty normal in my book.
Everything's hunky dory even.
Maybe even dory hunky, OK.
I knew that couldn't have been the end of the game. It couldn't end so succintly
So something to do with this boat must be a deeper part of the mystery here
In fact maybe its an umbrella corporation boat, who knows?
But there's something else here...
And we're gonna find it ou - oo I got some scars
I got some hefty scars
Aaah, I don't have my infected fungus strength!
Ho boy
Oh no
Oooh noooooo
Ohhhhh. Oh no
Good thing I had a flashlight
Oooh no
There's black goop raining from the ceiling
So it seems like this infection have spread pretty far
For as much as they've been doing this for the past 20 years I can't believe...
No one's noticed it up until this point
Mmmm. Mmmnuuuuh Just
uuuuuuugh
Just
BWEEEH
So lovely to get my tootsies wet in black goop
Oooh boy
Oh boy oh
Heey boyo!
Can I grab any of these pipes?
Y'know, for felf didthfonce.
Y'know, you heard what I said and I meant what I said
Oh fuck
Oh, that's closed off
Hello?
HOOOOooooooooOOOOOOKAY?!
I think it was a ✨flashback✨
If I know anything about storytelling clichés it's a flashback.
eyeyEyEyEYEY...egh
The walls are crawling with heeby jeebys among other
drippy goopy things
Hokay. Just ramdom noises.
Oh fuck JUST RANDOM NOISES.
Oh fuCK
Just random, body shaped, black oozy things
Oh Ethan? Is that you baby?
A kiss will bring ya back to life!
aMUAH
Nope. Just gross
Fuck dude, what happened?
This seriously, this black goop has a life of its own
That was evident in the dad fight, the black goop has like completely taken him over;
even though he had his same mind I guess.
Whatever mind he had left after he was driven mad
Ooh no
Oh no
Ooh, gross
Hellooo? Could I get a gun?
Could like I get a knife? Or  a sharp stick?
Maybe a rock would be nice?
eyeyeyeyey
What's down there?
Oh, it's locked. ~~Mysteriously~~
Alright, I don't see anything else.
ayeyeyAAAAAAAAAAAY
wOOAH what the fuck?
They're all dead! Blow it!
Oh, it's open now! For some reason.
Oh, ok, alright.
But that makes sense now.
I wanna point out something, I wanna take a little moment to point this out;
If you remember in the very beginning video where Mia was giving that babysitting update,
She was by an ocean.
"Maybe this belonged to the crew."
She was... literally behind her-- the backdrop was an ocean...
Maybe she was on this ship,
And maybe her unexplained disappearances are her working her job
At Umbrella Corporations, and she's not a-
She's not a long distance babysitter oddly enough!
Yeesh
Alright, okay, alright...
I still wanna go baaack!
I still would like to go baaack!
Ah fuck, dude...
Is there anything down here that I need?
I know it's a dead end I just- AWH, see, that's exactly why
Yeesh-I just wanna make sure I get absolutely everything that I possibly can
Leave no stone unturned anywhere I go-
UuULGh...uulghh
OOOWWWW!
Good thing this black goop cushioned my faaaall...
Oh boy...
Let's keep at it
Yeesh...
Is that a shutter door? Okay, so that's sealed off...Probably for containment or whatever...
But for some reason this ship ran ashore
And maybe that's where they found Evaline
I mean Lucas is still around, they were talking to Evaline
And Lucas was definitely still around...
Oh geez...
Hello?
Yee...
Okay;
"Captain: Ed Carlile. Paul Fitzgerald." Okay, this is just everybody that's on boarrrd...
None of these names  stand out to me so...
I'm not assuming-"She's not my child"
*mumbling*
I dunno.
Wooooah
Hi there. How ya doing, ya just resting up? Okay, alright then
Trying to hide I suppose...
Yep... I already knew that was coming.
"He must have been hiding from something."
And got black gooped in the process...
Alright...
Hmm...
Strange
Hello?
"She's inside me. She's inside everyone"
So sheeeee...seems to be the physical embodiment of this disease
Of this fungus; whatever you wanna call it, she's seems to be... either the source or patient zero
Y'know what I mean? So...
This black goop is literally HER
And this funnngus- can keep people alive...
That doesn't mean that it's goooooood...
Because it can also apparently kill people
And that is a lovely idea...
Alright, well this looks awful. Like what the hell happened to this? How did this entire ship rip in half!?
Like I can understand it crashing on shore and kinda getting banged up and everything but-
It's LITERALLY torn in half. It-
Like either something exploded...
Cause' look at that! Look at the damage; it's just sheered off and black goop is EVERYWHERE
Just twisted metal and concrete...
That's fucked up
That's fucked up...WOAH
WOAH
NO I'M NOT EVELINE!
How are you doing?
*Mark mocks Eveline*
*continues mocking her*
Okay... Alright then
Maybe the- Maybe the little girl isn't actually a physical being?
Maybe the little girl is like a...mental...
projection of sorts
Uuh...
And somehow the serum just... negates it all
Yeesh...
Alright...
I dunno if I wanna remember anyway-
I mean, A- After I've been cured, am I immune to it now or...
Would I have to be re-serumed over time?
I mean I have a funny feeling that Ethan needs to be serumed real bad
Hup-a-doo-ba-doo-ba-doo-ba-boo-ba-doo-ba-doo-ba-doo
Oh geez...
Euuglh
Eeuglph
Ah he didn't make it. He tried, but he didn't make it
Yikes
Down we go...
Okay-
I dunno what's pushing me deeper into this place other than pure curiosity
Hang on. Gotta see if there's anything under here
Anything in the underbrush? No? Okay
Carrying on then
Oh boy...
Helloo?
Okaay
I dunno about that.
Euuah! I said! *mocks Eveline*
Well aren't chu just a little brat!
Huh?!
You wanna fight?!
Oh okay
Tired of waiting...
I suppose you've been waiting for a good, long while-
But that also doesn't explain...
If the- If the people in the farmhouse have been doing this for a long time then...
There's gotta be something else to all of this...
There's gotta be another- whoo...
I cannot fight that! I cannot fight that! IIII cannot fight that!
I cannot! I cannot!!
Can I hide? Can I get a gun? Can I get a knife!?
Could I get literally anything to break open this biioouxx?
Gun? Oh herb oh okay alright I'll smoke away my toubles
Great
Fantastic. Wonderful.
So happy about this. 'Cept I'm not
Not happy. Mad. I'm upset
But still I'm brave...
Woahh
Alright so,
I imagine that in this box is something incredibly useful. It's gonna change my life
*Mock fear* Ohh...Ohh! Guh!
So I guess I just gotta hide from the thing...
Ohhhh...Which way ya going?
Oh it's coming this way okay
So it's just makin' a loop!
So if it's just makin' a loop...
I might be able to get away from it
Hello?
Can I get somethin'?
Anything useful? Chem fluid? Welp, still doesn't help me
But at least I can- I can make someeeeeee first aid!
Ok, alright
Give me something gooodd
*kind of singing* Give me somethinggg gooood
ok
So its slip slappin' along the wayHEYYAY!
WOAHHHHH K! ALRIGHT! GIVE ME SOMETHING GOOD I SAID! NOT SOMETHING BAD!
NOT SOMETHING GOOD AT KILLING ME!
Woahhh fuck! Oh fuck dude!
Whaheyheyheyheyheyhey!
EeeeEEEEEeeeeeEEEEEeeeeeee
Ah fucking come on!
K. Alright it's fine. Everything's fine
hughh
Everything's fine. OH FUCKING HOW MANY OF THEM ARE THERE!?
TWOOO!?
fuck
Oh God
I just gotta get around this one
Through that door
Woahhhh
EYYyyy
yE
ok
Just what the fuck is it doing?
Ahh fuck
I got 40... what!? Machine gun ammo!?
I want a machine gun!
Why haven't I been able to get a machine gun?
ok
So what I gotta do... I just gotta wait for it to go back...and sprint through that door
It's not gonna see me
How could I see me? I've only got a bright light shining in its face
k good
EYEYEYEYEYEYEYEYEYEYEY!
EYEYEYEY!
ohhHHhh
ok, I'm safe in here for some reason
YAYYY!
HANDGUN! GOOD! Finally!
Ok so at least I'll be able to do that
*mumbling to self* Writings in there...
ok, so I can save
But I'm gonna intentionally save in a place that's different in the last one before the serum
Just in case...I have to go back and see that
Because I will do that. I will go back and see if there's like, multiple endings to this game I wanna make sure I can get to them
'Cause this game is...fuckin' aowsome...
Wait I only have 2 bullets for this!?
Ohhhhhhh God noooo!
Ohhh nuoooh
Ok so the smart thing to do would be to use this to break open the biiouxxxx
eyeyey
eyeyeyey!
eyyyeyeyeyey!
and once I break open the biiouxxxx...
hopefully it's gonna have something that's aaAHH useful to me
oh jyes please
Gunpowder! That's not fu-- OHH IT IS-- AWWWW I FUCKIN' NEGHMAHHH!
I fuckin used the chem fluid to be able to make somethin' else
ok
Iz alright
It's alright
It's ok. It's perfectly understandable
Everything's ok. Everything's fine
I just gotta be able to get past...
this other one
So if I can score a sweet headshot...
I would be super happy
*half singing*la-ba-do
anybody in here?
ouu
I see a fuse!
Oh God ok ok alright bye!
Ohhh fuck ok bye bye bye bye bye!
Bye bye bye bye bye!
Bye bye bye!
Bye bye!
Bye byeeee!!
Buh byeeeeee
Alright, woah shit!
That was a thing right BY MY FEET!
EYY FUCKIN' COME'ON!
*mild singing* WOAHHHOHWOAHWOAHHOOHOOHHHHHHHHOHOHH
Ok
Jesus I'm gonna...
I'm just gonna have to get through all these fuckin'...
fuckin' floors aren't I?
It's like that game! I can't remember wha- Monstrum! It was like Monstrum! You're lost aboard a ship!
eghh
That sounds like bad sounds
Ohh boy
Ohh boyy
ohh yo boy yo
alright
Anything here?
Helloo?
Um Hello? He-Hello?
yeeee
uh hello?
hello?
Kid? whathcha' doin'?
watchin' your favorite cartoons?
Aww! Yeah my favorite too!
Hii
Ok I am watching it
ok! Alrigh alright! It's ok! It's cool! I'll watch it! I'll watch it
Just as soon as I-AH BLAM! Aw I can't even aim at you
I guess...killing a little girl would be...Ohhhhhh...Ohhhh ohhh
Alright then
What have you got for me?
I'm watchin' it I'm watchin' it okkk
"Test subject E-001. Sea Transport Log - Top Secret. Mia Winters"..."Cabin"
So she was aboard this boat...
So she was babysitting the girl
Ok Evie, where are you? This is not normal...
Oh no
*Mark reading paper*
Ohhh...
Oh! I just had an idea!
What if this...isn't Umbrella Co.?
What if this... is an opposing company... and Umbrella Co. is trying to get it?
Because... fungus! That's not Umbrella's M.O.(mode of operation)
Their M.O. has always been virus. They've always originated everything they have from this old flower way back in the day
But why...?
Why would there be anything else?
That's fascinating
I didn't think there would be another company but of course it makes sense. There's always competition
There's always competition in whatever you do and maybe they were attacked by Umbrella Co.
She is close isn't she?
Ok, Where ya at Eveline!?
EVEEELINEEE!
Eviee!
Where ya at? Oh so you're in there are ya?
Ohhh I see...
Where ya at? Huh?
Ohhhh...Hello?! Good thing I can gather things in a memory...
Oh geez
That would make-...that would make complete sense...
Maybe not complete sense but it would make a lot of sense
So I just have to remember...
to always do that...
Wait I just have to remember to do that? What the fuck am I talkin' about? I just have to remember that there's other corporations involved...maybe
Maybe...
So she's gotta be over here...
Maybe through here? Evie!?
Hellooooo!? Evie? Where you at?
You through there? Should I crawl through this hole?
That's probably where you is, isn't it? I'm just trying to make sure that I get all the items around here
Ohhhh...Well that's not good. Evie have you been a bad girl!? C'MON!
What're ya doing here? I told ya not to goop up the entire ship! Oh shit!
Well I can get out that way...That's a handy dandy tool to know
Alright let's try to go here. Evie where ya at? oh C'MON!
EVELINE!
Woahhhh...
K that's not Eveline
Uhhhh...
That's so bizarre
Wait so if this was a few years ago then that means that the family-The Baker family wasn't doing their experiments on Eveline alone
They must've been doing other stuff
They had to have been doing stuff prior because they've been doing it for 20 years it said
Or maybe they're just happened upon this and found a new purpose in life
Maybe...Anything's possible
Alright where she at? Where she at? C'mon! Eveline where ya at!?
Where you at!?
Huhh?
Where you attt? Or I'm gonna climb out here for some reason
Seems like where she might have gone
Alllright
Whyeeee bop bop...mmbbbop... Woahhh I'm not used to this gun OK!
Woahhhhhh...ok!
Ok that took a lot of bullets
But I also missed, like, a lot soo not really worried about that. I was terrible. New gun. Everybody forgive me!
It's ok! I know exactly what I'm doing
Alright so she isss where...?
Not through here is she? Hello! Oh ok you rest up ok
OK so where are you-Woah I saw that!
Aw C'mon Eveline!
EVELINEEEE!
UGHHHH!
FINE
Guess I'll just wait here patiently for the elevator and I bet there's gonna be an enemy in it
There's gonna be an enemy
Wookay
Woah wait woahhh!
Miss me!
No no no...
Oh she-it's dead ok
Well I just shot it enough. I gotta aim for the head though. This machine gun doesn't have stopping power
It's got a lot of bullets and rapid fire and that's all cool and all but...definitely doesn't have stopping power
ok...So I gotta get...number 2?
Oh I'm on 2. S2. There we go
I didn't know exactly where I wasszz
Okkkk...So I gotta be smarter about this 'cause I'm using way too many bullets
I know there's gotta be a way to hit 'em in the head
Repeatedly...Effectively
Ohhh she's near
Where you at Eveline? C'mon! C'mon out!
Don't be killin' nobody! Don't be turnin' them into goop! Come-OOOHHHHH...
What're you doing?
No
Miss me
Yeah I was hitting him in the head a lot that time it's still just...
It takes oodles and oodles of shots to get him down...Woahh
Eveline don't run away c'mon! C'mon be nice! C'MON!
C'mon out! Please? Pretty please!? With a cherry on top!? I'll throw you a birthday par-OHHHH
Get my buddy Lucas...(to) throw you a birthday party...
Woahh! Man that was close. I need more bullets and fast
She keeps just getting away. Farther and farther
There's gotta be more bullets or I'm gonna be reduced to a knniffeee!
I don't know if I want to go toe- to-toe with one of those things with a knife!
I mean I can and I will but...I just don't want to
Euughhll! Goddamnit ok fine then!
You wanna go toe-to-toe?
Boink!
What if I cut off its leg or something like that?
I mean, I'm gonna aim for the leg
Nope, not even enough to take it down
Aw c'mon I blocked!
Woah ok that was surprisingly effective!
I mean I-I hit so...
Do I have any goop juice? I don't have any goop juice do I?
Goop juice doesn't exist yet! Maybe I can eat this herbbbb...
oh
OHHHHHH!
OH I CAN JUST EAT THOSE!?
OH I CAN JUST EAT THOSEEE!!!
OH MY WHOLE WORLD IS ROCKED TO THE COREEEE!
I CAN JUST EAT'EM!
HOW AM I-HOW LONG HAVE I NOT KNOWN THAT!?
I COULD JUST EAT 'EM!
Oh but I prefer goop juice as my healing vehicle
I mean eating herbs is fine...edibles is cool and all but...I wanted some juice to splash on my arm
And only my arm
Alright fine whatever
That is knowledge I should've learned a looong time ago but...oh well. Oh!
Alan doesn't sound too good...
But either way!
Uhhhh, what I wanted to say about the families-Eveline found the family-The Baker family and made them their family. Definitely
So maybe they did have a farm originally and maybe all that was...just a part of that but...
There's something that goes on with this girl and wanting to be a part of a family
Woah...Cool! Just corrosive acid great ok good!
Yeahhhh chem fluid. GODDAMNIT I JUST ATE THE HERBBBbbbb...!
AGHHHLL MAKE A PSYCHOSTIMULANT I GUESS!
Fine! Maybe it can help me find iteeemssss
Don't know why I have them
What've we got? Huh? what've we got there-Ohhhh you are hidden away
Any other items!? I'm gonna go for a run
Just to make sure. I know I've probably passed by oodles and kaboodles of them
Or maybe there just aren't that
Oh my God there's so-OH MY GOD HOW DID I MI-OOOOOHHHhhhhh man! This is- this is embarrassing!
Ohhh this is embarrassing it was-that was right in front of me!
Ohhhh this is embarrassing. Oh hehe! Hoho!
Well I can't go that way yet but- hoho! Hehe! I-ohhhh this-ohhh that's embarrassing!
Oh this is embarrassing! Hoo that's embarrassing!
Oh boy I missed a lot ok. Ohhhh I'm so embarrassed. I'm so embarrassed. I am so embarrassed
Let's make a big one of those. Make another one of those 'cause I should use that 'cause I need that apparently
I need that a whole lot. Ohh a whole lot. Oh boy ok
Alright! Well I'm an idiot but oh well!
Let's melt this lock down
Apparently there's a lot of items through here too
SQQQUUUUuuuuUUUUkkkkk!!
Sqonk! Ohhh nice!
Hey she's not here!
Alan you've lied to mee!!
Alright well I've got all those
Oh no that wasn't the correct door was it!?
Ohhh I've gotta go further! Ohhh ok! I just had (*mumble*) for that
Well that's handy. I got a lot of items off it
So then...It's like an even better lock pick!
SQUUUEAKKKK! Nice! Gonna make another first aid!
I don't think I need it just yet but I'll-I'll-I'll keep it in my back pocket for later
YES! VERY!
uhh- I think she very clearly said mommy, Mommy!
Evie! Oh no...I'm getting readings all over the place
Hello! Evie! Where you at Evie?
I'll be your mommy I guess-Oh hi Evie!
*Mocking Evie's laugh* Heheheheee!
Evie c'monnnnn!
Oh boy
Okayyy...
Alright then. Well everything seems to be going to shit! Which is awfully nice
Also I don't know how...How in the fuck...did Eveline make a tape like this?-Woahheyyy
Eyeyeyeyeyeyey!
Eyeyey! Don't even!
Ok that one's dead!
I know I'm doing a little spray-and-pray but it's all I got at this juncture
With a machine gun like this, accuracy is out the window
Alright so there's gotta be a way. I probably just gotta go all the way back up-ohh nice smoke! I like that a lot
But I probably just gotta go all the way back up!
To a...woah!
There we go! So hard to hit the head!
I gotta do controlled bursts. C'mon C'mon!
What're you doing?
Ow! Miss me!
*popular laughing tune* Ha ha hu ha haaaa! You got stabbed to death!
Alright anyway. Time to move on!
Completely out of bullets so I just gotta rely on my- my wits and my skill of which I have neither
So...Hopefully it's not too much farther to the elevator and just getting the fuck out of here
Ah no more no more no more!
Evvvveeeelineeeee!
Evvvvelineeeeee!
Uh oh. I might be getting cornered here!
Evie... Evie!
Evie c'mon...c'mon...Evie oh my gosh. Sqoooosh! Alright let me in let me in
Lets go to...3 I guess? OK!
How am I doing on health? Ahhh I could use a sploosh
SPLOOSH ME! BLULULULULULU! Ah! OH!
ok!
Alright!
Ohhh shit!
Sh-Do I got to Alan or where do I go!?
ALLLLLAN!
Alan!
Alan? Uh oh
"Evie's upstairs"...Well that's no good
I don't think Alan's gonna answer. If Alan's not here, where the heck do you think he is?
Alright then
Offu we go...That's locked down...
I'm- can't believe I'm- oh I can take the uhh... the these
Huuuuuohhhhhkay what do we got?
Just one thing over there? that's it? that's really it? That better not be it!
That better not be fuckin' it!
That better not be it! Ohhh it' it isn't it? Damnit!
Ok I'll grab that...Ohhhh there we go!
Ah Ah! That souds bad! AHH FUCKING FUCKING ASSHOLE!
FUCK YOU YA FUckin' douche!
Fuck you! Yeahhh you wanna mess with me? Huh!? Fuckin' let me by!
Let me byyyy let me byyyy. Just ignore me I'm not I'm not important!
Give me that. How did I miss that? I'm an idiot. That's whyyy...
Shit! Eyeyey
I missed something in here
k. Herbs. Good. I can make a first aid at least
How do I get upstairs? I have no idea
Ohhh shit! ok this way
Alright! Anything down stairs that I need to know about?
Goodies goodies gumdrops?
Anything? Anything? Aw c'mon there's gotta be something. I was actually looking this time!
Son of an ass!
Alright carrying on upstairs
It has occurred to me that I have not idea how to use this bomb
But I have faith in my abilities as a gamer to know...That I am smart!
I am not smart...I am not ready for this and it is too dark to see shit!
Oh boy
okk
Alright anything here anything here anything good?
Oh this is where Mia was! Oh I was comin' out the way I just came!
Ohhhhh ok!
Alan!? ALLLLAN!
Alan?
How ya doing Alan?
Ohhh don't be so melodramatic about it!
WELLLLLLL...Welll wellll!
I seem to be infected with something!
hmmmMMMMMMmmmmm!
This probably ain't good!
Oh no yup! Yeah that's bad! Yup that 's probably pretty bad!
Yeah I can only imagine how bad that might be
For anybody that is...in anyway...infected by a horrible disease
oh what is this? What is that? Some kind of bomb?
Oh nooo this is- this is some kind of kit!
It's something-it might be a bomb I have no idea it might be a bomb...I have no idea
Ohhh boy
I don't feel so goooood...Oh what's this?
OHHHHH! OH MY GOD! ohhh this is my laptop!
Ohhhhh? oh shietttt!?
Oh shit
Yeah. ok. yeah
It's from the beginning of the game!
That's quite a good bye
Have a good life!
Have a good old jolly life! Have a good time! Bein' alive
And all that jazzzz
woahhh
Woahhhh ok! Eughhh
Alright then. Ohhh no!
Ohhhh!
WOAHHHHH...K!??
I don't think that's a good thing
NGGGHHHNNN PERSONAL SPACE IS VERY IMPORTANT!
O boy! Ohhh shit!
Ohhh ok! alright then!
Ahhhh...Ohhhh...KABOOMMM! BAM BABY!
Oh shit!
Ohhhh... So it was a combination of the 2! Primarily explosions is what did that!- ohhh
ok. Bye Mia
So primarily explosions is what did that but...
Ok...Hello darkness my old-Ohh hey!
Welcome back!
Ye-noo
Repeat it for me
Mayyybe
*mocking Evie* Hahaha
Was that supposed to be a jump scare? You're not very good at that...sorry
Fr-From a guy that knows a thing or two about jumpscares, I just wanted to let you know you're not too good at that
So either way! That looks like, the end of this episode but we got a bit to go
I-I was thinking. I was liked surprised that the game would've been over that soon but I'm hoping there's a lot more to this because we still have to look up...
What the origin story of this girl is, what company we're working for, what happened to Ethan cause it was obvious that Ethan was taken away
It- Whether or not there was even a choice to use it on the dad or not or else he would've just killed you
So...I don't know what would've happened if you picked Zoe!?
What would've happened? I have no idea...it's just...there's a lot of questions there that I wanna know the answer to but...
There's a lot of questions. If it gives you the choice, that usually means (Outro music kicks in)there's a choice behind the choice
But we'll see about that! Thanks everybody for watching and as always, I'll see you, in the next video! Buh byeeeee!